[Musique]
c'est dans la salle des fêtes du bocage
à sainte-suzanne que s'est déroulée la
traditionnelle cérémonie des voeux du
président du département aux agents du
nord et de l'est et une bonne santé mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de dire bah tout
le bien que nous pensons en tout cas moi
particulier du travail de nos agents
dans l'ensemble des services nous sommes
au contact des habitants d administrer
des familles en difficulté et le rôle
donc des agents du département est
essentiel c'est l'occasion pour nous de
rappeler l'importance de tout ce travail
l'occasion de remercier les agents pour
leur engagement et leur dévouement à
travailler pour l'épanouissement de la
population réunionnaise et l'aménagement
du territoire le département et la
machine la plus grosse de lille ça mais
la jambe et elle fonctionne
remarquablement bien confèrent les
chiffres que j'ai montré il ya
évidemment toujours des marges de
progression notamment au niveau
managérial et on sait que la qualité de
vie au travail l'ambiance collective
tout simplement la joie qu'on le peut
mettre dans l'exercice de son travail
que c'est un facteur déterminant de la
réalisation des missions de meilleure
façon qui soit un événement qui vise
également rassemblé les agents pour un
moment convivial de partage de bonne
humeur
qu attend pas mais c'est une bonne
équipe on fait une bonne dose de travail
et du couvent en à des événements comme
ça on vient ensemble on se regroupe
sacré de la convivialité je pense andreu
dans le service même et ça permet
d'avoir des meilleures relations
humaines
la santé et twitter que les contrats
sont renouvelés voilà c'est difficile en
ce moment de trouver un boulot
donc moi j'aimerais bien rester encore
un peu avec
le conseil général je pense que c'est un
acte ii
belle rhc comme on peut dire intéressant
est superbe à l'horizon pour les agents
oui il faut continuer c'est une très
belle journée on est tous ensemble il ya
de la musique il ya des bons repas tout
se passe très très bien c'est super le
président a réitéré sérieux dès le
lendemain sur le site de mon caprice à
saint pierre cette fois ci pour les
agents de l'ouest et du sud
nous sommes aujourd'hui à saint pierre
et à travers mon déplacement dans le sud
ce que je veux démontrer c'est que le
département est présent sur tout le
territoire de la réunion et nos agents
quand ils sont dans le sud
éloigné de saint denis ont besoin aussi
de considération et de notre
connaissance poil tout le travail qui
est effectué alors je suis heureux de
venir ici pour leur souhaiter une
excellente année 2020 je salue tout
particulièrement les assistantes
familiales
les travailleurs sociaux sans oublier
toutes celles et ceux qui travaillent
dans tous les services du département et
pensée particulière pour tous les agents
qui ont travaillé sur les routes
départementales
suite aux grosses plus qu'il ya eu il ya
eu beaucoup de dégâts et notre service
des routes a été réactif mais à 6
octobre et on peut le voir bonne année
une année 2010 marquée par la
recentralisation du rsa effective depuis
le 1er janvier dernier qui permettra de
dégager des marges de manoeuvre nouvelle
pour déployer des politiques de
solidarité de la collectivité
[Musique]